remember at the beginning of the
lockdown when I warned you about how the
Democrats and their allies in the media
and medicine even would try to use the
excuse of the pandemic to keep the
economy closed as long as possible and
then foist a new normal on us as a
society just forget about shaking hands
we don't need to shake hands everything
that comes into the house I wipe it down
packages mail on everything voting my
mail is just an opportunity to make it
easier for folks out there
well we return to normal I don't think
we return to normal oh come on past 14
days that's basically all out the window
over the weekend in LA in Philadelphia
we had huge crowds before that
widespread riots and we had widespread
looting so much for social distancing
but meanwhile millions of Americans are
still living in Democrat states like
California Virginia Illinois Michigan
they're still standing on those stupid
red dots outside the hardware store
don't you love those are the arrows of
the grocery store it's ridiculous and
the left
seeing how compliant so many Americans
have been is now on to the new new
normal okay so under this new new normal
you have no right to an opinion that
conflicts with or cause them to question
any aspect of their campaign to
destabilize America through bullying and
violence just as the editor of the
Philadelphia Inquirer who was fired for
the sin of this headline buildings
matter - well at least he only lost his
job when you physically defend your
business or home you could end up like
David Doran left to die in the ground he
was allegedly murdered by this man there
are no televised memorials planned for
captain Doran at least that I know of
now in this new new normal if you lose
your business to looting or fire we are
supposed to empathize with those who
carried it out because if you do that
demonstrates a higher recognition of
your privilege and it's new new normal
it's perfectly acceptable
to assume the worst motives on the part
of anyone who doesn't repeat the
progressive mantra du jour warning a
friend of mine you know posted something
without posting anything about a hashtag
black lives matter we should be so
disturbed in the way that we are that
you can't help yourself let's speak out
white silence is incredibly powerful
it's not neutral it acts like a weapon
it's not even silent like it speaks
volumes right so you get it you'll be
forced to repeat after them or else and
inspired by Al Sharpton's long history
of shaking down corporate America
they're now demanding that businesses
write fat checks or risk being branded
insensitive at best racist at worst and
without even knowing how the money will
be spent
fearful wealthy elites are falling all
over themselves to appear the most woke
the events of the past week have created
a sense of true urgency that has arisen
across our nation particularly in view
of the racial and justices that we have
seen in the communities where we work
and live we all need to do more
again those are comments from Brian
Moynihan the chairman and CEO at Bank of
ammo of America on this new commitment
that they're announcing a billion
dollars additional over the next four
years well JP Morgan CEO Jamie Dimon
even went to a local branch to take a
knee in solidarity but will the money
really buy them protection I guess until
the next round of demands which of
course is any minute now well we'll find
out
but the subjugation and self humiliation
that we've seen over the past week is
truly nauseating if you thought the
performance activism of white liberals
dramatically dropping to their knees
fists in the air wasn't bad enough well
you obviously miss the new trend foot
washing stations for activists and yes
they're man by liberals with almost a
religious zeal and don't think of having
ad next to your name even if you're a
far left Democrat
don't think that's enough to save you in
this new new normal The Pajama boy mayor
of Minneapolis found that some of his
new friends in the riot and protest
business or it's so friendly after all
jacob frye we have a yes or no question
for you yes will you commit defunding
Minneapolis Police Department
[Applause]
I almost felt sorry for him now watch
how the media operates in this new new
normal ever so gently tiptoeing around
Marxist masquerading as humanitarians do
you understand that the word dismantle
or police free also makes some people
nervous for instance what if in the
middle of the night my home is broken
into who do I call yes I mean I hear
that loud and clear from a lot of my
neighbours and I know and myself too and
I know that that comes from a place of
privilege I guess you're supposed to
call the white privilege hotline no I
wasn't clear on that there was virtually
no follow-up to that moronic answer by
the way
now this lunacy is gaining traction
across America in like a dozen other
major US cities that seem to agree that
worrying about home invasion is really
just it's racist from LA to New York
mayors and City Council's are looking to
strip funds away from police and then to
reallocate them to communities of color
now presumably they think that
communities of color don't need
protection from criminals of all colors
and ethnicities or is it that they don't
deserve protection in order for
guilt-ridden liberals to feel superior I
don't know it baffles the mind now this
lunacy is even gaining support in
Chicago which over the past two weeks
since the killing of George Floyd has
had at least 48 murders and even more
shootings the overwhelming share of the
victims were African Americans when we
did our two town halls in Chicago we
found that the people there wanted more
police presence not less won't that make
people feel like they're more on receipt
or you're saying it'll make them feel
safer it'll make them feel safer we need
back our programs that we used to have
on the police department like officer
friendly the Explorer scouts take the
youth give them something to do when I
worked in 29 years everybody that knew
me knew I was a good cop
now this confirms what a recent YouGov
poll found despite calls by activists
and protester defund Police Department's
close to 2/3 65% oppose cutting police
force funding just 16 percent of
Democrats and 15% of Republicans support
that idea also of note is a recent
Monmouth poll check it out which found
that in the last five years overall
satisfaction with local police has
increased among black Americans from 50%
at least somewhat satisfied in 2015 to
72% now so is this push for a new new
normal really really about equal
protection equal treatment under the law
and justice for a lot for all well
listen to the cries of women business
owners like this you said black lives
matter
why don't you choke me I'm black look
what you did to my store
[Music]
well if black lives like hers were
really the focus we would all all of us
know her name
celebrities would flock to her store and
those of thousands of others and help
them rebuild and protect them from
future harm look as we've said many
times on this program the killing of mr.
Floyd was an absolute assault on
humanity and the use of his death to run
a proxy campaign for a political
candidate I'm gay if it was a Democrat
this time would be a Republican some
other time
it's a transparent insult to our
intelligence just like wanting us to
believe that a heavily edited interview
by CBS of Joe Biden tonight means
anything significant Biden claimed he
did not approve of the black lives
matter demand to defund the police no I
don't support defunding the police I
support conditioning federal aid the
police based on whether or not they meet
certain basic standards of decency on
honorable ascend in fact are able to
demonstrate they can protect the
community and everybody in the community
honorable Ness well the poor guys not
capable of doing a live long-form
interview without serious lapses and
thought and focus yet we're to believe
he's going to keep the country from
burning down once the BLM and and Tifa
folks really start issuing ultimatums I
don't think so
well of course Joe though let's get
straight here he's hoping that the
campaign will really just be 2008 all
over again you don't have to accept what
was considered normal before you don't
have to accept the world as it is you
can make it into the world as it should
be and could be you can create a new
normal one that is fairer and gives
everybody opportunity and treats
everyone equally and builds bridges
between people instead of dividing them
now wait a second I could have sworn
that he was President of the United
States for eight years so should we
consider only the past three and a half
years is not normal
oh I didn't President Obama solve all
these problems if he knows what we
should do well tell you why because
these issues are really complicated no
one wants to live in a police state and
no one wants to live in a racist state
when the hard left suggests otherwise
they're lying and they insult the
hundreds of millions of Americans who
work hard and live in peace all over
this country and that's how they want to
live in the future this is a great
nation filled with good people if
they're racist police they should be
fired if there are abusive police they
should be criminally prosecuted . but
the less big idea of defunding the
police will lead to a dramatic increase
in pain suffering and death but they
don't care although most Americans they
do that's why President Obama didn't
push for it that's why Democrats like
Nancy Pelosi are afraid to vote for it
that's why the American people will
never stand for it
defunding the police is a ludicrous
position that should never be taken
seriously but too many Democrats have
shown that they cannot be trusted to
stand up for law-abiding citizens
against criminals with a purpose and
come November millions of us will
remember that fact and that's the angle